All right, you're done.
Let's go look at the solution.
Where we left off last time,
as you can see,
we have two empty queries
for LOCATION_ID and LOCATION.
These two queries look a lot like
the queries we have for Weather.
For LOCATION_ID,
this looks almost exactly
like what we do for Weather,
except we use a hard-coded query
rather than relying on the one
passed into the function.
Since we know that this is always
going to be a long integer value,
it is easy to just build the value
into the query string.
LOCATION, on the other hand,
looks almost exactly
like the Weather query.
We just pass all the parameters
into the database.
You didn't think you're going
to get away without testing, did you?
Don't worry, it's really easy
to add this test.
It turns out that calling
our function within the provider
works almost exactly the same
as the way we did the weather table.
All we have to do is replace
WeatherEntry.CONTENT_URI
with LocationEntry.CONTENT_URI.
And of course we still have to delete
the two columns that we can't support.
Now that will actually work.
So, let's test that to make sure that works.
And our test passed, as expected.
The interesting thing about this test
is that it's just only testing
the first query
and it just happens to work because
we deleted the database before the start.
It'd be much more interesting to query
for the row that we just inserted.
And this will test the other query.
Now, let's run the test again.
And those also passed.
So, we have some of our queries within
our content provider functioning.
But unfortunately,
we still have to do some of the
more complicated things in the provider.
Let's talk about joins.